кривавий pad так описує за
сіднейського експерти в ієнну ситуації
в Україні немає через три з половиною
вранішнє після початку розв'язану
росією uwaine і через завзятий опер
українців російські нас тут впораємося та
сторони додали більше проходить до
позиційних боїв
російсько такому вона поки що на
проканало цукор новачка і лихо ладу на
і упаковані все можемо ніби мовляв він
ослаб кисті піхоти
батальйонно-тактичних груп через c
головну ставку до води труби ти на
артилерію то встановлення залпового вогню
відсмоктування брюнетки в умовах місця mail.ru
небагато тебе зброя виражаючи вали тепло
ща я нас тверджу ще удари по цивільних
об'єктах тут не ціна вниз на алла
російської давність 2 телком СНІД
це хоче у хони розумні батіг і там ще
площа врожаю настінку залучає
pitbull він споживає ворухнути або його
не нації бути з відома
він вас на google now рядів і
прес-конференцію берліні чого ж ти не
представляє міністерство оборони не
зморшки прокоментував ситуацію так
відразу милу ми в краю важливо стажем і
потім що вид буваєте в Україні але важливо
врятував 3-х і ми за геєм та російською
сторони можна створ чогось ще
російська сторона було здорово на
йому вірним і під затишним духом про пару
українців та україну за нашими відтінками
маруська сторона своїм загартована раху
волосся
[музика]
вести герострат ставок і вид конкретніший
хоч і ніг так так і ви та не бойових дій
представлених уряду 7 все значення
жертви серед мирного населення
заслуговуєте на бундестазі проти
парламентському комент ці випробування
барони поважають негайно на рази
роботу все ще можна
на мою думку не менше на роботі з і
щипить примати україну моно зустрічаємося у
вину баз по середньому тихон їх від шуму ми
не хочемо воювати з росією біля лами Петра
йому йому українець з бро вина стиль кіно
стіки можна його постільці у нас їй не на
така багата ми перевірили арсенал і бунда
сферу то й відправляємо утащу не шелом це
комплекси для типу вітринного захисту
подалі позиції перевіряються ми також
відправляв і підлогу фото боєприпаси то
хтось ще майма то й відправляємо їм їжу
жив важливо стажем і за ситуацію
німецькі експерти у праві завданої
тримайся а тато ряду ще удари по
цивільним телем посил у цьому в тебе
краще видачу російські весь до проходить
готова ще ботафого ти місця то ви до
ростову 3 артилерії та ракет це
крилаті ракети і тим самим втече і в
витратою української сторони то посил цей
позов на Україну
рагна не досі ти військового успіху ти
дали пустили в цьому і вся цьому робити
миття ставка на оружні не ще виражаюсь
волоку плащу на вигляд велику світові ніжно
за вітриною сили ще до скронь та авіації
потрапила вона здавала щось ще українською
скронь і за вітриною посилайся і сунути і
подруга ще росія дасін і завоювала
повний контроль впали 3 так само
російська сторона збентежена ви до зростання
аватарок цієї великої дальності
запускаються xru сиську краще Білорусь
coupe вітряного просто ru china по
іншу злочинність у за вітринами у
просто рі україни
Андрій
одні з тіла та російського наступав було
закуплено серце України до його клешні
командувати військами США в Європі
Ходжес сумнівається ще армія р.ф.
завались дат на
я думаю ще росіянам не в дасті, а той
а ти київ а там більше закуповуєш і його 9
скільки годин ви не допомагаєте за копито
маріуполь для росіян сама лаби ніби
найпростіший місця для хобл і не
проходьте близьких з них військового
флоту то силу криму то на донбасі all i
wanna do сини змивається і зруби ти п'яний
і віруючий розумних та чоловіки весь
фактичного точить і крил я був там
адже теж не тому я був там кей-кар
Зевса душа душа була до місця наберіть
одні з найбільших лічок Європи навіть
складні низький рельєф у росіян на травень
під уже нас ти ще відучить і його
роботи прогнозу ще вдома живих термін
то подалі відходу бойових дій експерти
вид ми вливається на тонну апарат шину
розвиваєте ситуації в Україні